[موسيقى]
ما تشاهده هو صاروخ يتم
نحته بواسطة طابعة ثلاثية الأبعاد عملاقة ،
وهذا حقًا
يصنع ميزة الخيال العلمي لمضاعف الرحلات النجمية التي
رأيناها في الأفلام لعقود عديدة ولكن
لم يحاول أحد البناء بهذا الحجم حتى الآن
لكننا نفعل ذلك ، تيم إليس هو
المؤسس المشارك والرئيس التنفيذي لشركة الفضاء النسبي ،
يعتقد إليس أن فريقه قد وجد
طريقة لصنع صواريخ أرخص وأكثر موثوقية
باستخدام طابعاتهم ثلاثية الأبعاد التي
أطلقوا عليها اسم stargate
وما هي مزايا الطباعة ثلاثية الأبعاد
إنه صاروخ نعم ، لذا فإن المزايا
تدور حول الأتمتة وتقليل عدد الأجزاء ،
لذا عادة وفي الحقيقة على مدار
الستين عامًا الماضية ، ما زلت تسير في أي
مصنع طيران حول العالم
أو صواريخ أو غير ذلك وما
زالوا يصنعون منتجات واحدًا تلو الآخر
يدويًا  الملايين من أجزاء القطع
الفردية وهذه المصانع العملاقة المليئة
بالأدوات الثابتة التي تستغرق مليارات الدولارات
في سنوات لتأسيسها وتكرارها
وتغييرها ، لذا فإن أسلوب الطباعة ثلاثية الأبعاد
الذي نقوم به هو حقًا مقدس  جريل
للأتمتة
والفضاء وطباعة الصواريخ يعني
أن النسبية يمكن أن تبنيها بشكل أسرع. يقول إيليس إن
فريقه يمكنه حاليًا طباعة صاروخ في
حوالي خمسة أشهر ويعمل على تقليص
وقت البناء هذا حتى أكثر من القدرة
على بناء صاروخ في 60 يومًا و 30 يومًا هو
هذا  السرعة ضرورية
حقًا لأنها
تتعلق بمعدل التحسين ، لذا أعتقد أنه
يمكننا كل 60 يومًا إنشاء نسخة أفضل ونسخة أفضل ،
لذا فهي حقًا
تتعلق بنوع معدل الممارسة لأن
الناس يتعلمون بشكل أسرع بكثير من خلال العمل بدلاً
من مجرد المحاكاة
كيف يؤثر نهجك على
تكلفة الصواريخ لأن الصواريخ كما
أشرت باهظة الثمن بشكل لا يصدق
تقليديًا ، لذا فبالنسبة
للصواريخ الأخرى من فئة الحمولة الصافية المماثلة التي تم بناؤها
تقليديًا ،
فإن صاروخنا يبلغ حوالي ربع
التكلفة وبالتالي فإن مركبات الإطلاق الأخرى
تطير حاليًا
هذا هو تمزق واحد هنا ، هذا هو
طفلك ، نعم ، هذا هو الطفل ، لذا ،
نعم ، هذا هو
الأول في العالم.
[موسيقى]
جسم صاروخ مطبوع بالكامل ثلاثي الأبعاد
تقول الشركة إن الأرض 1 ستطلق في عام
2022 ، إذا سارت الأمور على ما يرام ، فستكون
أول مركبة من بين العديد من مركبات الإطلاق ،
وسيطبع فريقه في مصنع شاطئ كاليفورنيا الطويل ،
في الواقع ، تعمل النسبية
بجد بالفعل  على
صاروخها الثقيل الأكبر القابل لإعادة الاستخدام ، تارانار
واو ، إنها طابعة خطيرة جدًا
، نعم ، إنها حقًا الأيام الأولى أيضًا ،
أعني
أن وصول إليس إلى الفضاء هو مجرد جزء
من المهمة التي تغير بشكل أساسي
عملية التصنيع للأشياء الكبيرة
باهظة الثمن  مثل الطائرات أو
توربينات الرياح لا يقل أهمية عن
أننا بدأنا بالصواريخ ، لكنني
أرى حقًا أننا أول
شركة طباعة ثلاثية الأبعاد لطبقة التطبيقات في العالم ، وأعتقد أن الطباعة ثلاثية الأبعاد
ستكون قادرة على بناء
منتجات أفضل بكثير بشكل أسرع ، إنها حقًا تتعلق
بزيادة سرعة التعلم
وتقليل الحاجز أمام الدخول
لمحاولة تجربة ثلاثة
اثنين
وصفر واحد
إذا كان كل هذا يبدو طموحًا للغاية ،
فهذا لأنه  يتمتع إليس والعديد من أعضاء فريقه
بخبرة كبيرة في بناء
الصواريخ لشركات مثل الأصل الأزرق
و Spacex وقد جمعوا أكثر من مليار
دولار من التمويل في العام الماضي فقط ،
لكن النسبية لم تضع صاروخًا
في الفضاء بعد ،
أنتم يا رفاق تبنيون صواريخ فيها
طريقة مختلفة تمامًا في صناعة
تنطوي على مخاطرة بطبيعتها وحول
الحد من هذه المخاطر ، هل كان الناس
يشككون في هذا النهج الجديد ، كما
تعلم ، لقد قمنا ببيع صواريخ أكثر من أي
شركة أخرى في التاريخ قبل الإطلاق ،
لذا أعتقد أنك تعرف أن الناس واثقون تمامًا من ذلك
بيانات الاختبار التي أظهرناها
لهم اليوم ، لكن الدليل موجود في
الحلوى ولم تسافر يا رفاق إلى هنا
لم نقم بالطيران بعد ، لكن كل
الزخم موجود وأنت بالتأكيد على
حق علينا أن نظهر ما
لدينا  لكن أجزاء كبيرة من الصاروخ
قد نفذت بالفعل مهمة محاكاة
على الأرض ، ولذا فأنا واثق تمامًا من
أننا تجاوزنا الحدبة حيث أصبح
صاروخ الطباعة ثلاثية الأبعاد أمرًا لا مفر منه الآن